hello hello everybody as you are joining
us here
this fine fabulous day
hope you're all having a fine fabulous
day so matter where you are whether
you're just getting started already
through it
coming to the end we are so excited to
have you here with a stock live
um this program is being brought to you
by askdoclive.com
and
we want to make sure
that
if you have spoken to anybody
about any of the supplements that will
be spoken about today or if somebody
specifically
said hey watch this show plug in ask
questions make sure you get back with
them
if you have any questions or want to
make an order okay we are a resource
here for an amazing community that is
sharing the hope of alternatives and
empowering people to take control of
their own health
so
whether you are
deficient or sick
and want to work on yourself
in changing that
or if you are super healthy and you just
want to stay super healthy for the
decades to come we're here for you as
well so we don't leave anybody out but i
want to make sure
that you do get back with the person
that referred you to this program
so as stock live
we are a place where you can come and
ask a real naturopathic doctor who has
decades of personal
research
in the veterinarian world in the human
world at the pathology
level
so
i think that it's a very unique unique
situation and i am very blessed and
honored to host this program and my name
is rebecca kozak
my hosts with me today
are jonty mccollier and ruth ellen
sanchez and if you are on live with us
and you have a question go to that zoom
menu and raise your hand i will be going
back and forth between
the hands that are raised
the questions in the chat and emails
that have come in
and getting those answers for you from
a very very amazing doctor
who who has not spared any expense than
being able to bring the truth
to the worldwide population
now the content of this program is to
provide educational information only
on the importance of nutrition and
supplementation in a world where the
food supply is empty and void of
what the body needs not just to survive
but actually thrive
the fda does require us to let you know
that our products are not meant to treat
prevent diagnose or cure any diseases
and this program is not meant to take
the place of your primary care physician
but we do bring the good news that news
of hope
that
whatever your family history is
and what's been labeled as genetic does
not have to be your story
epigenetics is the study of how your
behaviors environment can cause changes
that affect the way your genes work and
with epigenetics you are empowered as an
individual to have more control than you
think over your own health journey
and we invite you to feel the difference
with the options shared in this program
and to guide us
it is absolutely an honor to have one of
the founding fathers of the science of
epigenetics
to help us
with what we need in order to maintain
or obtain
optimal health
dr joel
wallach welcome dr wallach
thank you so much for once again taking
time out of your busy schedule to be
here with us
um it is such an honor and we appreciate
you and your time so much
well thank you for the kind introduction
all the kind words and thank you john t
and ruth ellen the staff appreciate all
that you guys do
um
and of course
i'm very very excited you know that um
we're talking about epigenetics i'm
considered one of the founding fathers
of epidemics along with bruce lipton uh
he is a neurologist
and i am a pathologist and so we both
came to the same conclusion many years
ago
that there were no genetically
transmitted diseases there are no
genuine transmissions
and
this is very scary
to
[Music]
people because their doctors said look
you have this genetic disease you have
five generations of a
autoimmune thing going on in your family
well there are no autoimmune diseases
there are no genetic diseases when a
doctor didn't know the answer they would
blame it on your bad change or your bat
your family's problems or your body's
attacking itself and all this kind of
stuff to kind of take the pressure off
of them
and
dr milan and i we went to china we did
one study where we did one thousand five
hundred autopsies now i take the pack
one thousand seven hundred autopsies
i take that back one thousand seven
hundred seventeen hundred one thousand
seven hundred autopsies
of kids under the age of 10
who had died suddenly of a heart attack
this is called keyshawn disease in china
again 1 700 autopsies
and
we were able to show that the cause of
cystic fibrosis thought to be the
biggest
um example the greatest unimpeachable
example of aging transmission disease
was just a simple nutritional deficiency
of a single mineral and then also
that um
the the um
disease
okay
um let's see here
we have cystic fibrosis musculosphere
the disease most christian was thought
to be a genetically transmitted disease
and of course uh jerry lewis very famous
jerry lewis a comedian but he had the
telethon and for 20 years he raised over
2 billion 2 billion
for the
um muscular history association and we
gave him all this data that we got from
these 1700 autopsies
and uh he got so excited because he
talked to the doctors who signed off on
these charts that dozens and dozens of
these kids with much history with we had
reversed the disease
on them they're back to normal
and so and he took it to the musculus
association they fired jerry lewis and
shut down the telethon after he had
raised two billion dollars for them
and then
as a sort of a side light on there
um we wound up also getting rid of
sediment death syndrome which doctors
said were caused by mothers laying on
their babies at night when they're in
bed with their babies no ninety percent
of the babies that died of um cinnamon
syndrome and cribs by themselves so i'm
the one who made her change it to crib
death but also the two percent
that were in bed with their mothers when
they died they weren't laid on by their
mothers they died of this hypertrophy
cardiomyopathy heart disease called
keyshawn disease in china
and
we did this study in heilum zhong
province in harbin medical
school at the kishon hospital
and
published in three languages
and i received the klaus schwartz
award
for this which is kind of like the top
um
award for biochemistry other
the only thing that would be higher than
that would be the nobel prize i was
nominated twice for the nobel prize on
this but because it flew in the face of
everything that doctors believed
um i was not awarded the nobel prize
otherwise nominated twice but i did get
the klaus schwartz gold medal so very
very proud of that
now
this keeps going forward here
there are no gently transmitted diseases
in the book epigenetics really everybody
needs to have at least one of those in
the household
it's about two inches thick but it goes
into the history of all these
these incorrect
um
interpretations of observations
because the doctors didn't have the
backgrounds they didn't have the science
uh they weren't trained in these things
and so they're just making
um what should i say loose judgments
uh based on what they had heard as
opposed to what they were seeing
well
uh epigenetics and there's a cd that
goes along with it and then there's a
follow-up
book
called hell's kitchen
hell's kitchen
came along
uh because
of all these pandemics we were having
you know we had the spanish flu we had
the asian flu
we had the swine flu
we had
the
h1n1 we had the h2n2 we had
sars mers
we had covet two and then we have
coveted 19 with all the variations and
everything i guarantee there'll be more
pandemics when this one's over okay
because people aren't listening they're
not solving the problem the problem is
you have to take your 90s essential
nutrients and i always say praise the
lord and pass tonight we actually have a
cd and a dvd set labeled that way praise
the lord and pass the 90.
because this was based on a
a situation where he had a pastor up in
baltimore maryland a pastor
okay
um by the name of mike freeman and he
was in a coma for i don't know three to
four months and the doctors you know
told his family look he's probably got
less than a week to live
and so one of her great distributors up
there
in baltimore maryland linda tyler she
called me and said hey anything we do
for this guy i said well does he have a
g2 it can give him our supplements
through the g2 and she says no
okay what i want you to do is he's
married right yeah we'll get his wife
and yourself
and get a couple of quarts of our
plant-derived cold minerals the liquid
minerals and take two cup fulls a day
one cup full in the morning and one cup
full in the afternoon
of the plant derived colonials and use
some cotton balls and rub them all over
his back or his legs whatever his
exposure is chest whatever is exposed
in three days time this guy who was
supposed to die
okay from this coma he was in
oh he gets up and goes back to the
church and he gets on his tv and his
radio station which was attached to the
church and put out the word and so forth
and had me fly out there
and he and i put together these
interviews
um a zoom interview and uh a
cd
and so this is all on these
the dvd and and the cd called praise the
lord and pass the 90.
and we're working on a big big project
now to deal with it again
to help people support their immune
systems because all this pandemic stuff
going on because there's another one
coming
and um and so it's one of those deals
where
people really are only beginning to
understand
that
these diseases
are
simple nutritional deficient diseases
there's over 600 different nutritional
deficiency diseases
um and
this is one of the first places that
people knew that there was things that
we needed for health was salt
and you know to medical doctors salt is
the big enemy that's because salt saves
your life
and so you go back
to the beginning of written history
and the first supplement that people
were actually
evaporating salt water and taking the
dried salt and selling it
that was the first supplement programs
out there thousands of years ago
okay sodium chloride every cell in your
body needs it your stomach needs it to
be able to make hydrochloric acids it
can break down proteins into amino acids
so you can absorb iron and b12
and so salt has two very very important
uh nutrients in it um
okay sodium
and chlorine chloride okay sodium
chloride well
um then doctors have demonized that
because it benefits them when they
demonize salt
okay it benefits the medical community
when they demonize salt
and so we have a pink himalayan salt
that was made when the oceans went away
up in the himalayan mountains some
thousands of years ago
and it left all these salt deposits
and of course when we learned about this
we also get our minerals there because
when the oceans went away all the all
the reefs died and all the algae that
were with the reefs they
they you know the organic material went
away but the minerals were there so we
get these our plant minerals at the same
place we get the the pink himalayan salt
and so we have all these very unique
products
and so we have again
our motto is praise the lord and pass
the 90 we give god all the credit
but we're making sure that everybody has
opportunity to take the 90th century as
60 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12 masses 3
fatty acids
and really the only other products on
the market that
beat their chest and claim their
complete supplement program only has 27
nutrients in there it's not even a third
we're going to get the others okay well
that's why we have this program and
right now people are streaming to us by
the tens of thousands every month
all over the world we're in 60 countries
we have warehouses in 60 countries and
we are growing like crazy
and so this is because people know that
their medical systems have failed them
no matter what language they speak no
matter what countries they're in no
matter what color they are no matter
what race they are no matter what gender
they are it doesn't matter
you need the 90 essential nutrients
okay and then there was another piece
that was missing um absorption uh gluten
which people have been eating
uh and you notice that there was no
gluten i went back and looked many many
times
in the old testament and looked at the
the things were growing and the garden
of eden the garden of eden was primarily
herbs
and vegetables there were no
grains there was there was no wheat by
the way or oats in the garden of eden
now once people start eating wheat brown
rye and oats it kills your intestines
and causes irritable bowel syndrome
diverticulitis crohn's disease celiac
disease
um all those are caused by
gluten
and when your intestinal villi the
little finger like things go away
suddenly now your your intestines are
like a plastic tube instead of a shag
rug you lose 98 or more
of the absorptive surface
and even if you're supplementing you're
not going to get the results you're
hoping for
so you have to get off the glute
and
we have my newest book
which is out has been out now for
oh
i'd say since uh august has been out
since august
so about four months
and uh it goes into
uh gluten-free cooking and doctor while
he's cooking without the bad foods and
um all these chefs are just were all
over me well we can't make meals without
gluten you know everybody has to have
bread and spaghetti and noodles and
and um oatmeal for breakfast and
pancakes and waffles and
flower tarteism they said no they don't
okay the longest of peoples in the old
days and the bible in the old testament
you know they're living 800 years of age
they didn't have any gluten okay so
let's look at that well it turns out
that this gluten of course is the thing
that produces a chemical that gets those
villi to die and go away and so now you
have a smooth like plastic tube as an
intestine instead of a shag rug with all
that surface area
and so there's two things you have to do
to maximize your health number one get
rid of the bad foods out of your diet no
fried foods no processed meats no also
glutens and so you want to get a hold of
this book dr walsh cooking without the
bad food there were three professional
chefs in eastern canada
these are guys who had tv shows big
restaurants big hotels and so forth
and they just wouldn't believe me so we
did a three year study and we got
feedback from the people who were buying
the meals and everything that i had set
up my recipes and after three years they
had to agree that i was correct
and so we came up with this book doctor
walks cooking without the bad foods it's
300 pages
of gluten-free
and healthy cooking
no frying and all that kind of stuff
and so
it's one of those things where it's a
beautiful thing this book is going out
like crazy right now and of course it
makes a great gift for holidays for
birthdays for graduations just because
you love grandma and you want her to you
know add 20 more years or 50 more years
for her 80 year old life
um get her that book um
and
you know i talked to somebody the other
day whose son was in rabbinical school
going to be a rabbi and he was sick
okay at 20 years old 19 20 years old you
know just in his early stages of
rabbinical studies
and but he was sick in the hospital
because he had all these problems
well was he taking supplements no what
was he eating gluten what's that well
bread and
um tart i see here well they ate matzah
bread well yeah you know that's what
hebrews do well that's why they have all
these problems they're related to the
hebrew people because they're eating
gluten gluten gluten gluten and they
don't supplement okay and so
this is one of those things where this
is very simple stuff
it's very very simple stuff and even a
little kid can understand it
okay
and so
um
it's it's um one of those things where
jerry lewis was so excited
and he took the the
prevention and cure
for muscular dystrophy
to this through the musculature
association they fired jerry lewis and
shut down his telethon after they had
raised two billion dollars for him
for them excuse me for them
um
they're crazy and instead of saying well
okay we got to research this here before
we make any public announcements but
they didn't they just just some merely
fired him when he walked in the door and
told him he was all excited and he gave
him a little presentation they fired him
instantly what a terrible stupid thing
they did and of course since then 2011
you haven't heard anything about the
telethon who
um the monsters association who
because they shot themselves not only in
the foot but the chest and the head
and so it was it was a crazy thing they
did
well right now
um we have all these various medical
associations
uh coming to me we have more and more
medical doctors joining us in youngevity
now i was kind of shocked i said
we had how many this month medical
doctors joining us
because they see what we're doing
around the world in 60 countries
okay we have a cd called the red warning
lights there's like i don't know eight
or nine different
diseases
um
that are caused by nutritional
deficiencies these are red warning
lights they're telling you
for instance if you have gray hair
um you're in trouble
not because of aging gray hair has
nothing to do with aging is caused by a
nutritional deficiency babies are born
with gray hair
okay
um
michael jackson
had vitiligo
which is kind of related to gray hair
and varicose veins and hemorrhoids
they're all caused by the same
deficiency
and he had vitiligo he had lost his skin
color in patches on his hands and his
legs when he was a little kid four five
six years old and the doctors told his
parents
uh that
this is genetic nothing too but put
makeup on him if they wanted to but
there's nothing they could do about it's
genetic thing and by the time he's a
teenager his hair turned snow white and
the skin on his hands and face was white
as a typing paper so they put all these
um makeups on him and drew pictures and
things on his face with makeup and
lipstick
and put gloves on him with all the
jewelry and everybody thought that was
because of his entertainment stuff
okay but it was covering her up all this
white skin
and he died at age 51 of a ruptured
aortic aneurysm which is caused by the
same deficiency that causes the gray
hair and vitiligo
and
varicose veins and spider veins and
hemorrhoids
so had many many years of warning
warning warning warning but they're just
doing surface um cosmetic
issues as opposed to getting down to the
root cause of the problem and so this is
what the book epigenetic is the book
epigenetics you know really really can
add 25 to 50 healthy years your life if
you go there you will be amazed
at the all the diseases that are said to
be genetic or not you know lupus is not
an autoimmune disease it's actually just
caused by gluten
intake and multiple nutritional
deficiencies
and you know you get the rosacea in
their face they get these psoriasis in
the skin
rheumatoid arthritis is not an
autoimmune disease is caused by a
nutritional deficiency arthritis with a
secondary infection with a bug called
mycoplasma which is killable with an
antibiotic called minocycline so you get
on the healthy bone and joint pack and
msm and some vitamin d3 and are
beyond osteofx liquid and our collagen
peptides you throw all those together
and
then
um you take that
and you add you know six to eight weeks
of a prescription called mental cycling
i don't care if you've had rheumatoid
arthritis for 40 days in less than 90
days it's gone usually in two weeks
you're seeing magic in six weeks you're
seeing really magic and and within two
months it's gone
because none of what the doctors was
saying was true
and so this is
unimpeachable
stuff it's published in the book
epigenetics
and it's one of my best-selling books
and i urge everybody to have at least
one of those in the house
and no matter what um
your kids are going to do when they grow
up
they need to be
reading that book
grandma needs that book
you need to give one to the pastor to
the rabbi the imam
okay and so forth and everybody who
deals with people
should have this book epigenetic
and also
hell's kitchen
this goes into the switch from
wood as fuel for stoves and
and fireplaces to electricity
um the wood ashes have been used by
human beings for
thank you
for
oh gosh
since the beginning
of humans they put wood ashes in their
food they put wood ashes in their
gardens
and there's all this was our source of
minerals our that was our source of
nutritional minerals when we switched to
electricity nobody said you know now
we've given up the wood ashes here to go
to electricity and so now we need to
start consciously supplementing with dr
wallach's vitamins and minerals to make
up the difference because there's no
more wood ashes available to us which
has been our
since thousands of years has been our
source of nutritional minerals okay with
that i'm going to turn this over to you
rebecca
thank you for holding up those books
yeah so so one thing i wanted to point
out epigenetics the death of the genetic
theory of disease transmission
i mean that says a lot right there
yep it says it all in the title
and and you know people may not
understand what epigenetics well that's
a foreign word
but the death of a genetic theory of
disease
transmission i mean
transmission means spread people yep
and through this through this i'm the
guy who got rid of sysbarbosis i'm the
guy to get rid of muscular dystrophy and
i'm the guy that actually um
got rid of sudden death syndrome now how
many people get rid of three diseases
like that two which are thought to be
genetic and the other one thought to be
the mothers laying on their babies i'm
the guy that got rid of those and that's
why i got that klaus schwartz award
and
did i get invited to speak to medical
students no did i get this invited to
speak to
pharmacy school students no did i get
invited to speak to nursing school
students no
um did i get to speak to
naturopathic schools no did i get to
speak to veterinary schools no they all
just kind of hunkered down and shut up
they didn't they were afraid
that
that if i went there and spoke their
schools that people stopped donating
money to them
[Laughter]
well dr wallach so
you're only 83 years you've got another
40 years doc i i think things are
changing and we've got a lot of things
going on
um you are also the only
or the first recipient to
receive this clause swartz award who is
a naturopath and veterinarian
that is correct
it's like how many how many people do
you know
um go from one world where i mean you
love veterinarians
oh yes
veterinarians well i'm still a
veterinarian but you took all of that
information
and
expounded
yes well now you have to appreciate
rebecca and this is all said very
clearly in this book
that all of the first understanding
that these diseases were thought to be
genetic and autoimmune were not
was in the animal industry because we
don't have health insurance for animals
so the farmer couldn't afford
to invite the veterinarian out every
week to treat his animals
and insurance would pay and so
they
kept after the veterinary community the
veterinary community learned very
quickly
that all these diseases like arthritis
things like autoimmune diseases
uh genetic diseases we're all religious
caused by nutritional deficiencies and
that's why you have these pellets these
little alfalfa pellets and these little
um
bean like pellets for animals because
they have all the nutrients in them so
the animal can't separate them out they
can't just sort of look through the food
and eat the things they want they have
to eat everything including the 90
essential nutrients
and that's why
meat and milk and dairy
and um
those sort of things are so cheap
because
we don't have to have the veterinarian
going out and seeing these animals every
week and every day
because they are doing well because we
put all these nutrients into there and
they can't sort through them and the
whole story of how that happened
um and all the various initial diseases
we got rid of and of course in
racehorses they wanted to get rid of the
arthritis and and joint problems and
muscle problems those kind of things
which still plague
human beings
unfortunately and of course the
pharmaceutical industry loves it the
medical doctors well they'll say well
let's try this for a while if it doesn't
work we can give an artificial knee we
can give you an artificial hip we do
some back surgery
there's 25 different diseases that are
caused by osteoporosis in the skull
they don't even teach in medical school
that you can get osteoporosis of the
skull
and you talk to doctors they they we've
never heard of that and they look at
them say it's never been published that
there's osteoporosis in the skull
that's how ignorant they are
there you go
it's all in your head
yeah
thank you to the next collect dr wallach
and
let's let's talk about
just how
well
with the osteoporosis of the skull we're
looking at bones
and and their structure
but with the bones in their structure
it's also related to connective tissue
that's correct well the basic sort of
um
rebar if you will
the basic
material of bone is is a connective
tissue okay and um
it's the same stuff that tendons and
ligaments
are made out of and the skull is like
more than 50 percent this connective
tissue
all right and so
when you get obviously close to the
skull it goes from being a quarter of an
inch thick to an inch thick
okay and it's called paget's disease i
wanted to change the name from padgett's
disease to wallach's disease because
paget
over 100 years ago thought this was due
to an autoimmune disease they were first
talking about autoimmune disease a
little over 100 years ago
and so
um they thought this pages disease
osteoporosis was an autoimmune disease
and so doctors don't pay attention to it
because they think it's autoimmune
disease but naturally it's just
osteoporosis the skull and you have all
these tunnels that these 12 pairs of
cranial nerves go through and the spinal
cord goes out of the back of the skull
people don't realize it but your spinal
cord is not formed in your spine it's
formed in your skull in your brain and
then comes out of the back of the skull
and
when your skull gets to be an inch thick
the tunnel that the
spinal cord goes through gets about half
the size it should be sort of squeezes
the spinal cord
okay
and you can actually be born paralyzed
if the baby is born with obviously
approach to the skull it happens a lot
okay
um and so the skull is squeezing that
spinal cord
okay
and um it's called herbs palsy and um
then
uh it also squeezes maybe one or two or
three or all 12 of these nerves um
people know about tinnitus ringing in
the ears you had that that's an
osteoporosis is called squeezing the
auditory branch to the adrenal nerve
then when you get vertigo or dizziness
oh i stand up and i get dizzy all the
time you have that too and that's caused
by squeezing the vestibular branch of
the eighth cranial nerve and people know
about bell's palsy on one side of your
face group says squeezing the facial
nerve the seventh cranial nerve and then
there's trigeminal neuralgia the
fifth cranial nerve is being squeezed is
very painful
and then
um
you get ona optic nerve atrophy and you
just get a slow
loss of vision where you have to change
your glasses every six months you know
the prescription you have to change
every six months that's because the
optic nerve the optic artery and the
optic vein all being squeezed by the
skull
and causing all these problems
and then you have all these dental
problems when you're a teenager you're
growing right if you obviously approach
to the skull you got to go to an
orthodontist that's because you have
osteoporosis of the skull and your teeth
are kind of floating around because your
jaw and your facial bones are all part
of the skull
and so all this is totally preventable
and reversible with a supplement program
okay which we call the healthy bone
joint
program okay
and
um then of course we've
we created the the msm
so that heavy duty connective tissue
like
tendons and ligaments and
um fasciitis fascia the big flat tendon
like on the bottom of your foot oh i got
fasciitis at the bottom of my foot okay
plantar fasciitis well it's a big flat
tendon it goes from your heel to your
toes
and these things all require all these
nutrients
and
that's why we have these things we deal
with athletes i mean we have had
athletes that their careers were
destroyed theo ratliffs is a good
example
his career was destroyed he was 24 years
old and he was playing basketball for
the atlanta hawks and he had a 35
million dollar contract and like a year
into it they fired him because he
fractured his wrist as a shooting arm he
had bone to bone arthritis in his knees
and all the cartilage was gone the
cartilage went off as one of those hips
we came up with a healthy bone and joint
pack for him we came up with our rebound
response drink for him that's why his
picture is on the label of these things
and after three months on our program he
got his contract back for 35 million
dollars he played for 11 more years and
he made over a hundred million dollars
just because of the healthy bone and
joint pack and the rebound
fixed him and maintained him during 11
years of a professional basketball
career now we have two cds that i want
everybody to listen to to go along with
the book epigenetics in addition to the
cds episodes
one is called supplementation
okay or see
here
how's it going
exercise patience
there is yeah there you go exercise
without some limitation of suicide okay
and the other one is
um
dead athletes don't lie because you can
be making just like theo was making
millions of dollars but he wasn't
supplementing he's falling apart and he
lost his career if we hadn't come along
and saved him with the nutrition his
career would have been over and all that
potential those 11 years that he did a
great thing for the atlanta hawks
um and and his own family now i have to
give him a lot of credit
because
when he retired and actually a couple
years before he retired he took um
and set up a program for kids in his
community
and so all these kids after school
especially the parents are working they
get to go there he's got 300 kids that
go to this this center that he set up
for these kids after school and for two
or three hours every day monday through
friday um
they have mentors and trainers and boy
scout and girl scout leaders there they
have pastors they have rabbis they have
all these people there who are working
with these kids
and theo ratliff's
center for these kids and he's giving
back to the community and just it brings
tears your eyes of happiness because all
the things that theo ratliff is doing
for the world
all because of these supplements
yeah it's fabulous and dr wallach i mean
i used to supplement a lot
a lot and i kept going downhill and
downhill i was cherry-picking i would
hear about
this product you know this this
on this show and this nutrient from this
show and you know just
i i
was missing
well one it was the form two it was the
co-factors and three
it
i know that there was a lot missing
because i was taking probably about 30
40 different bottles most of them
individual supplements
and there's 90 essential nutrients were
you eating gluten back then i was
grinding my own wheat i was buying my
own wheat berries organic
and going by this thing called a food
pyramid
the seven food group pyramid
yeah where you know all of these grains
were at the top and you were supposed to
have those is the main thing
but i was growing my own vegetables
you know but
you know it just
i had to stop and think about it because
when i heard your show
and then i thought about what i had
going on which was
all connective tissue stuff for the most
part i mean i had fibromyalgia i had
degenerative disc disease i had a torn
hip capsule migraines tinnitus
um
the compression fractures which is bone
fiber i said fibromyalgia but carpal
tunnel
i had
the vertigo i had lit restless leg
syndrome sciatica plantar fasciitis i
mean all these things that you mentioned
was in one package
and i felt like i was dead
or i was ready to which brought in
depression
and i took your liquid form
of
what would be you know very similar to
the healthy bone and joint pack which is
the
um pig pack plus
which i am so thankful is still
available
and
within the month i was feeling alive
again and within three months i
i was able to move without any
restrictions
and and i then i heard oh i'm supposed
to cut out gluten
i'm like okay so i cut out gluten and it
just like poof got so much better so
faster
and i just can't stop
from sharing
what you have put together
with everybody i talk to
so and the fact that i'm honored to be
here and host you right now is like a
dream come true so
well you were probably chosen by the big
guy upstairs okay
i think you're an angel of god
and you know you lost over 100 pounds i
believe that yes i've lost 100 pounds
and
something that people have a hard time
believing that because i don't have all
this saggy skin
well skin
well skin is two-thirds of the thickness
of skin is connective tissue yes and
when connected to shoe who is happy
there's no wrinkles
i'm 83 years old and i don't have any
wrinkles you know
most people they look at me they say
well well like you couldn't have done
all these things you say you've done how
old are you and i said i'm 83 now what
oh i thought you were 50 okay
yeah i mean i don't have you know the
sagging
stuff it's like
taking the nutrients and adding the
glucogel and the msm ultra
and having all that work together
i think that's one of the biggest
parts dr wallach the body can absorb it
and it works together
so you've got it
it's
it's amazing
so anyways
i think
we need to um
let's get to some questions
okay
before we get to questions i do have to
or i want to actually remind you that
this program is sponsored by
askdoclive.com
which is a website that has all of the
replays from our askdoc live show going
all the way back into july of 2020
we have these available to you to be
able to watch and re-watch and share
with those you think of
about any condition i mean as you're
listening and you hear a condition that
yourself or somebody you love has share
this program with them so that they can
get nutritional
perspective
at how to
address what they have going on in their
body from the cellular level
but again if somebody referred you to
this program specifically
get back with them
and say hey i watched that program you
recommended and i want what they are
selling and it's not so much selling
this is a service
we are providing options that you're not
going to hear in mainstream media
because it's a lot it's a lot cheaper
than the medical approach and i was just
gonna say because
they're not making a lot of money off of
it
i mean this is something where we're
using food as nutrition and i love this
comment on the back of the hell's
kitchen it says eating as an art is very
old
but as a science
very young
and that's by charles king a professor
of chemistry at the university or the
columbia university
so we've got a lot of smart people that
listen to our program dr wallach
so whether you're into art or science
making sure that the food that's going
in your mouth
is
being beneficial
to your vessel your body
the greatest creation of all
is so important
so important
so and dr wallach um
yeah we wouldn't have this information
if it wasn't for all of your studies
but i
let's go to our first hand that is that
okay
and
mike
go ahead and unmute yourself
you are on live with dr pollock
hey doc first i want to say thanks for
all you do and we're very lucky to have
back
well you're very kind how can we help
you today
so i've got a client and uh he's 69
years old
six five
290 pounds
and he was just diagnosed with uh
prostate cancer
he actually has a tumor on his prostate
and uh that's where he's at for right
now he's he's now this just happened
this week
and now he's gonna go to a specialist
and they're gonna tell him what he needs
to do but what i wanted you to do is
maybe talk about a little bit about
prostate and men's health and then i
wanted you to give me your take on what
he should do
okay well a prostate is a sort of male
issue right
um just like men can get breast cancer
but it's very rare
but women can't get prostate cancer
because they don't have prostates
and so for prostate
and
we have a great prostate product called
prostafx it has all the nutrients that
the prostate needs and likes
but i choose when somebody has cancer
the prostate i choose not to give them
that product because i don't be driving
production of new cells
with the prostate effects
but um let's see it's six foot five 290
pounds if he's an athlete a muscle
you know bodybuilder might be fine
but i'd like to see him weigh maybe two
fifty to forty so maybe he needs to lose
40 50 pounds
and so just by getting rid of all the
bad foods he'll start that direction no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat no bread rhinos no
sugar no carbonated drinks all those
things contributed to him having cancer
and then it wouldn't hurt for him to
have a hair analysis you get the book
rare earthman cures in chapter 11 tells
you how to collect the hair how to box
it up or to ship it don't forget to put
the check in because they won't run the
test without the
check
and then um
we need to find out if he has any of
these toxic metals in there like lead
and
mercury and uranium and things like that
it's amazing how many people have large
amounts of uranium in their body
and so forth uh anyway
then at 290 pounds
um he could take three
of everything it's cause like one of
everything for 100 pounds of body weight
and so
i want him to take uh
if finances are not an issue you could
take three if finances are an issue i
wouldn't go below two
okay but let's go with three
because that's the ideal here
of the healthy painted heart pack that's
our big hammer in the toolbox uh full
dose everything that in that package at
breakfast lunch and dinner
and then i want them to have two bottles
a month of our msm so we can take three
of those at breakfast street lunch at
dinner time and they're designed to
support and promote maintenance repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue
discs between vertebrae and when you
talk about the bone marrow
with your immune system it also loves
this msm
because it's the bone connective tissue
that's making the white blood cells that
kill the cancer cells and all the
antibodies to kill the cancer cells and
so forth so that's why i'm throwing the
msm in for that
and then he also needs our killer biotic
which is the reishi mushrooms there's
like six other species of mushrooms in
there supports the immune system
pain relief
anti-inflammatory i also like the cell
shield rtq take three of those twice a
day
and it's also um supports the immune
system and anti-inflammatory and pain
relief and then the big one i would
throw in
three bottles a month
of our btt 2.0 tablets now they are not
an interchange with a btt 2.0
powder which is vitamins and minerals
the tablets
are designed to support your immune
system which is very important in this
case and also
an anti-inflammatory
and
a pain reliever so i wanted to take
three of those three times a day now i
take three
of the btt 2.0 tablets twice a day um
just just because just for prevention
i've been doing that for
30 years
and
when we came out with it
and so it's one of those things where
um
this is which they say
the appearance of cancer whether it's
breast cancer uterine cancer prostate
cancer colon cancer lung cancer
all these types of cancers are caused by
things we do
and
is make us susceptible because of the
things we don't do
okay
it's not autoimmune it's not genetic
it doesn't just happen
and so you got to stay away from the bad
stuff but let's get that hair analysis
and see if there's any toxic minerals we
need to get rid of we do have a program
for that
if there's toxic minerals in there which
would contribute to the cause of the
prostate cancer okay
so let's go there
and you know keep us informed as he goes
to the doctor and gets you know updates
and so forth and we always say give us
90 days
of a full-blown program
and let's see what goes on okay okay
great thanks doc appreciate it thank you
mike bye-bye
all right fabulous
now
dr wallach let's go to the first
question that i had emailed into me here
and
doria
has a it's her niece's son who is 16
years old i mean this is starting really
young doc
he's six feet
156 pounds he has lost over 20 pounds
since april
he started out with stomach aches
becoming became tired and then started
losing weight he's become lethargic and
food seems to go right through him
more recently he has gotten heartburn
and brain fog so far the testing that
he's had done shows nothing
okay that's a good thing now he's
another one that should probably get a
hair analysis because if all his
nutritional minerals are below the
bottom line that means he's not
absorbing that means he's got a gluten
issue the odds are he's got a gluten
issue was he eating oatmeal for
breakfast was he eating breakfast at
champions wheaties
does he eat flour tortillas at lunchtime
does he eat spaghetti at night does he
have chicken noodle soup um
yeah you understand what i'm saying here
does he have pizza with a flour crust
okay and so i guarantee he does and so
this kid has got to get off of gluten
immediately he's going to live like an
asian living rice and sweet potatoes and
beans and squash
and vegetables
and then at 156 pounds i want him to
have two healthy brain and heart packs
per month two healthy brain hard packs
for a month to photos everything twice a
day
i also want him to have the msm he could
go with one bottle a month take
um
three of those msm twice a day with
three at breakfast three at dinner time
he'll support and promote mains repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue disc between the vertebrae i also
want him to get our rebound uh his body
weight he could go through two or three
servings of rebound a day
um
uh we're kind of back ordered right now
in the cans because the people who make
the cans are having a hard time getting
raw materials
but we do have the powder and canisters
we do have
the powder in the individual servings we
get 30 of these sticks we call them the
individual servings of the rebound in a
box
and he could take two or three of those
rebounds the rebound is unique as a
sports drink it's not like red bull that
has caffeine and sugar in it uh our
rebound has 75 minerals and 25 vitamins
amino acids very important to your plus
energy stuff
and that's going to help him with his
tiredness and so forth but also have him
take
um our um oxy body
he could take uh get him two quarts of
oxy body he could take an ounce of
breakfast and ounce at dinner time
and
it wouldn't hurt in the middle of the
day to have our collagen peptides
i'd take three scoops twice a day and he
wouldn't hurt for him to take
uh say two or three scoops in the middle
of the day in addition all the stuff
he's going to take at breakfast in
dinner time that's going to help him
his joints and all that kind of stuff
and help rebuild his intestines but he's
got to get rid of the gluten no wheat no
broth around oats he cannot have one
cheat day a week
everybody in the household's got to be
gluten free
so he can maximize absorption here
so we can get maximum benefit from all
these nutrients and then
doria should contact us every couple of
weeks anytime he goes to the doctor and
gets an update and tests and so forth
but get that hair analysis because we do
have a program to detoxify people if
they do have
um toxic metals in them
and also it'll tell us if he's absorbing
the odds are he's not absorbing like he
says everything's coming through out the
other end
and he's got all these problems
including fatigue and tiredness and so
on heartburn
um you get heartburn
this can be caused by osteoporosis of
the skull squeezing the 10th cranial
nerve the vagus nerve yet
atrial fibrillation is irregular
heartbeat doctors think it's a heart
issue no it's osteoporosis skull
squeezing the 10th cranial nerve
but you can also
get really bad stomach issues called
gastroparesis which doctors can
misinterpret as having ulcers
and heartburn and that kind of stuff
i was just osteoporosis it's called
squeezing that 10th cranial nerve
and so because it goes right
by the heart and branches go to the
heart has branches go to the lungs you
get copd you get asthma
all kinds of stuff a hiccup a bounce and
hiccups but this kid
he will respond just like you did when
you got off the gluten and took all
those nutrients i think he'll have the
same benefit you did
awesome thank you so much dr wallach i
know that doria appreciates that as
she's on with us i just saw her pop on
next um we have a comment in in our chat
here and
good morning doc a client michael
weighing 180 pounds
um
43 years old his weight does fluctuate
his height is 5 foot eight and three
quarters
he has problems with his teeth
and a little fatigued at times
eyesight isn't good
last time
checking pressure was okay cholesterol
could be better
cramps at time only in left leg
because of diabetes
he has a little nerve
damage and
now and again a little dizziness
okay
well the dizziness
okay the tenth let's see here the
dizziness we're talking about the eighth
cranial nerve uh the vertigo dizziness
and this is the skull squeezing the
the um
uh
eighth cranial nerve
uh and then of course
the eyes
having problem the skull squeeze in the
optic nerve which is the second cranial
nerve
all right
and then
diabetes well that can cause fatigue you
know that sort of thing but
don't cold turkey off his medication or
diabetes but he needs to get on two
of um
bottles a month of the sweetie so we can
take three twice a day to sweeties and
then
as his blesser begins to come down he
can slowly reduce his medication based
on the numbers
um
the teeth i also want him to
take our collagen peptides he could take
a couple of scoops of that with his
drink in the morning and evening
he also needs to take vitamin d3 take
three of those twice a day that's two
bottles a month
i would also have him take
the um let's see here
recover diabetes
fatigue don't rebound we've covered that
rebound rebound
and the teeth issues i'm assuming he's
talking about cavities and teeth moving
around getting loose receding gums all
kind of stuff
all these things should get better
except for when you get a cavity in the
tooth it needs to be dealt with by
filling it
and of course
it's very difficult to kind of rebuild a
tooth but when you can
stop it from progressing by putting a
filling in there
and supplementing properly and getting
off the bad stuff you maximize
absorption
okay
all right sounds good now christy has a
very good question and the fact that i
spent a lot of time in front of this
machine here
she wants to know if the blue light
from phone screens tablets and computers
contribute to digitive eye problems
okay well i cannot answer that
correctly
because i have not looked up the
research on that so i'm going to do that
i will look up the research on that so i
can answer that question
but when people have a
gradual loss of vision
um almost always is because of
osteoporosis and skull squeezing that
optic nerve the optic artery the optic
vein
and you get like four or five different
diseases of the eyes when those three
tissues are being squeezed by the skull
and
doctors just say well you're getting old
you've got to expect that that's
nonsense okay babies are born with these
problems okay and i have people who've
been with me for
uh 40 50 years and they're
90 years old and older and they don't
have these problems because i've been
taking my supplement program for 50
years
and so
um i will but thank you for bringing
that up i will check that out i can
say from somebody that spends anywhere
from 10 to 14 hours in front of this
thing over the five last five years
taking the supplementation
my prescription is less
yeah it's gotten less
yeah that's a good thing
quite a bit i can actually drive without
glasses now
wow
just don't make me read any small signs
but i love the fact that i can do that
where i couldn't
before so let's go ahead and go to our
next hand up dr wallach and we have sam
sam go ahead and unmute yourself
okay you got way too much background
noise buddy
got it okay barbara thank you
all right
hey thank you doc love you and becca i
love you
okay you're very kind oh yeah no really
seriously so i want to i want to share
something a very good friend of mine
who drives a cab exposed to a lot of
people had been experiencing he thinks
it's the big c okay that he had right
dizziness respiratory issues and he was
basically able to overcome it using the
silver nano hydrosol
with two 15-minute sessions a day and in
two days
gone
so it's such a a simple technique to use
and uh i just want to
send that out to everybody right and uh
thank you yeah
all right so the next step is to get him
on a protocol to prevent
i am i'm working on him to become a
health coach he's aware of it and he's
pretty sharp so i'm i'm working on him
to you know to help other people as well
as himself but uh
you got to start by doing it first you
even drivers even drivers need nutrients
right drivers need more probably right i
think drivers need more because they
have to stay more alert dr wallach
yeah but
yeah
and and sam brought up a health coaching
program so part of one thing that is
available to the community
is the certified holistic health coach
program that is offered by the institute
of holistic health if you're interested
in that get with the person that shared
this program with you
or
you can also
go to institute of holistic health dot
com and that's holistic with a w
and read up some information on it
and go to the askdoclive.com
website and click contact us and we will
help you get set up for that
so
let's go to the next hand that is up and
lori
go ahead and mute yourself
you're on youtube
i talked to you a couple weeks ago and i
still i'm getting my money together to
buy what you suggested but i didn't
share was i had that camera capsule and
they were checking to see why i lost so
much blood but um you were just talking
about the villi and
gluten
is it possible to
grow back your villi
oh absolutely
no no i don't care if you're 150 years
old if you get off of gluten so i can
tell you have a gluten issue because you
have white hair
this is a very nice lips i noticed my
lips are really bad yeah so you you're
not making enough red blood cells
because your bone marrow is not happy
okay
and because you're missing nutrients and
your gray hair is a warning signal
there's something bad is going to happen
if you don't deal with this do you have
any varicose veins or spider veins your
feet and legs
a little tiny bit around my ankles but
my energy is extremely low and my brain
is not doing well
okay well that's because you have
nutritional deficiencies and i you know
if you've been eating oatmeal for
breakfast and the breakfast of champions
wheaties
flour tortillas bread
chicken noodle soup
no
you're telling me you don't eat bread
i do eat some bread once in a while or
fried food so i notice that in my hands
that i've got spots so i am listening to
your dead doctors don't lie and i'm a
health coach and i'm a holistic chef but
i just had some health challenges to put
me in a van so um i don't have a kitchen
right now
but um
let's get you let's get you
going here let's get you all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no wheat nobody right
no no sugar no carbonated drinks even
the diet one's got to go how much do you
weigh here
um i don't do any sodas um laurie how
much you weigh weight about
180. and how tall are you i'm 5 11. i
lost an inch and i know you're instead
of the osteoporosis of the skull
and i'm once in a while i get really
sharp pains in my left ear so i know
that's all
oh she
okay and uh let's see
um um how tall are you five eleven i'm
five eleven and i'm what's your age
i am sixty years old
sixty okay yeah and so
you're going to look 25 years younger
when you start taking this program and
get off of gluten and live like an asian
live on rice and see this morning for
breakfast i had three soft boiled eggs
okay
um the soft yolks i had a pretty good a
couple of slabs of the smoked
wild alaska salmon not from the farm but
wild caught from the river okay and then
i also had um let's see here i had wild
rice not fried but just steamed rice
wild rice and then i had two servings of
of yogurt that are sugar-free and
gluten-free
um
one was strawberry rhubarb the other one
was lemon and then i had all my
supplements
can i move in with you
well
what should i say we do have a big big
big laboratory and a
a warehouse for our books and everything
called wellness publications and we have
people who come and they spend a little
bit of time there we do charge them rent
and all that kind of stuff
but um it's one of those things we do
have people who come and want to stay
for a while and kind of see what goes on
that's one of our smaller facilities we
do have our big warehouse our production
and sales and shipping facility called
wellness
um
youngevity
and
we have warehouses in 60 countries
and we deal with 2 million
patients a month
all over the world okay on some days
i'll see 2 million patients
okay and i do this through
the the hands of you know like rebecca
and john t and ruth ellen like you know
how many people are we seeing today
through them
and teaching them to do all the right
things but your hair color will come
back if you do the right things and
that's telling you you're absorbing the
nutrients but you got to get rid of the
gluten you can start right away you'll
save a lot of money just by getting rid
of gluten and eat like an asian rice is
a lot cheaper
i don't have a kitchen
i don't care
you have a hot a hot plate or something
like that or a microwave or something
like that in your van
no microwave i got someone stole my my
uh stove i have to buy a new one
okay
you're finding every way you can't do
anything find a way where you can't i'm
gonna buy a new stove
okay i've got bone broth
i like rice
i had far for lunch and dinner last
night
okay so you need to move forward here
girl yep okay look for solutions lori
that's awesome that you're on your way
to finding those solutions
so we are at the top of the hour already
i cannot believe that we've already gone
an hour
so everybody go ahead
and get up and stretch and fill your cup
back up make sure that you're staying
hydrated and
getting some movement in that body as
many of you like me are just sitting
here listening and just taking great
notes and and just really being a sponge
to the information that is being shared
for those of you who are listening and
like oh what did he just say
what recommendations do i need for
osteoporosis of the skull or
you know any specific conditions all of
our replays are available at
askdoclive.com
and our incredible co-host jonty
moncollier is like johnny on the spot
when it comes to getting these posted
on
the website
sometimes within a few hours sometimes
the next day but
unless there's technical issues they are
always there before
monday so i just want to encourage all
of you to just focus on listening right
now and then go back
and we're going to write notes say okay
today is
october 29th and he mentioned this
condition so you can go back to the
website and pull the video up and watch
again
but again
ask askdoclive.com
if you have
questions don't know exactly what to
take and you were not
sent to this program by somebody
specific
again if you were sent to somebody
specif it's been sent here by somebody
specific
get back with them because they have a
vested interest in making sure that you
get what you need to have an optimal
life so i will be right back as well
again stand up stretch
fill that water cup put a splash of
minerals and we'll be right back all
right thank you everybody for sticking
here with us with ask doc live
where you are able to ask dr wallach
questions in regards to yourself or a
client or a loved one that you know
because this is a resource to help
spread
information that you're not going to
hear anywhere else
my name is rebecca kozak and i am your
host um and
we also have a call team that is
standing by for those again who were not
sent to watch this program by anybody
else
they have not spoken to anybody about
any of the supplementations that you're
hearing about today and that number is
eight five five nine four nine seven two
three four so dr wallach i see that you
are back i'm back
yes you are
and let's go to the next hand that is up
and we have
kelly
kelly if you can go ahead and unmute
yourself and if you're able to turn your
camera on that would be fantastic
i really would but i don't have a webcam
set up right now
okay
it says that you do it's just covered
back but
this is charlie or charlene kelly
okay how can we help you
hey um thanks for letting us come on the
show i've i've been for years trying to
figure out my son has um
uh like focusing like struggles with
getting distracted or focusing and i've
always wondered um if it
if it could be a deficiency or something
but i've never known
yeah how old is she
well he's actually 23. yeah okay 23 okay
and
how much does he weigh
i should have got that but i'm gonna
guess somewhere around um
160 something like that okay and how
tall
uh about five
five
yeah about five five okay any other
issues highway pressure diabetes
arthritis low back problems
pretty healthy kid except um he does
struggle with sleep
like getting to sleep or never getting
enough sleep
okay so sleep issues okay does he have
any skin issues eczema dermatitis
psoriasis acne anything like that
yeah well yeah when he was what he
ectopic dermatitis like if we rinse like
he
wash and um
rinse his clothes twice
okay
and
then mm-hmm okay and then any bowel
problems constipation diarrhea irritable
syndrome diverticulitis crohn's disease
celiac disease
i don't think so
okay
so
um yeah focus could be a lot of things
it could be low blood sugar could be
you know reactive hypoglycemia
it could be just simple nutritional
deficiencies
so the guy who's 160 pounds i wanted him
to get rid of all the bad foods no fried
foods no processed meats no oils no
glutens a wheat bar right now no sugar
no carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go
and then i want him to
take um
two healthy brain and heart packs per
month the full dose everything twice a
day i want him to eat three eggs twice a
day with soft yolks soft boiled soft
yolks salt poached soft jokes soft salt
scrambled butter
not fried not hard-boiled okay
that's three eggs twice a day because 75
of the brain weight is cholesterol
can't be living on a cholesterol-free
diet and taking statin drugs and
lowering cholesterol and have any kind
of brain function
all right then in addition to the two
healthy brain heart packs i also want to
have one bottle a month of the msm so we
take three of those twice a day in case
of getting osteoporosis or skull
i also want them to have our de-stress
capsules capital d like david stress
take three of those two i say it's two
bottles a month
and then
i also uh want him to have our sweeties
take our sweeties take three of those
twice as two balls a month uh just in
case he has a sugar issue
and then it wouldn't hurt for him also
to
get a hair nails says get the book rare
earthman cures and go to
drjwalk.com
www.drjwalk.com and get the book
rare earthspin cures
or maybe um you can
rebecca will put out their website so
they can get through them either way and
in chapter 10 11 i'll tell them how to
collect the hair how to box it up where
to ship it
don't forget to put the check in there
because it won't run the test without
and see if he's got any toxic metals
like lead mercury and uranium and weird
stuff in his head we'll find out if he's
absorbing because of all his nutrients
are down
that means he's not absorbing so all
these things be very important but the
diet is important to get rid of all the
bad stuff and especially the gluten
and then take the supplement program
and um
then for energy i want him to use our
rebound or sports drink he could take
two or three servings of that a day but
i wouldn't take it after four or five
o'clock because he might stay up all
night if he drinks it at eight o'clock
at night watching tv or something like
that
and find out if he falls asleep watching
tv after dinner that's very important
piece of information find out if he has
gray hair i know he's only 25 years old
but i've seen
three-year-olds with gray hair
okay because it's a nutritional
deficiency it's not a factor of age so
it gives us clues what's going on okay
okay
so he should see some remarkable i
always say give us 90 days but he should
show a remarkable improvement
wonderful
yeah thank you you betcha
all right dr wallach thank you so much
for that
and the next question or actually it's a
comment that carrie made in the comments
today that says he is talking to the
doctors of the home directly us
so i'm going to take that as a
compliment because i'll tell you what
i have my own best interest
at hand
and i don't have to pay somebody else to
get it
so
i apologize i missed what what he said
um kerry said he's talking to the
doctors of the homes directly us
oh well there you go
yeah
so and then curi uh laurie has a
question is oh actually she just danced
at that question so we'll go ahead and
skip that but tara has a client that's
dealing with hemorrhoids and is having
charlie horse cramps in her legs
she's 36 years old at 150 pounds
so what would you recommend for somebody
that's got hemorrhoids charlie horse
female 36 years old and about 150 pounds
okay
i would guess that she has gray hair
also she may also have varicose veins
and spider veins because they're all
caused by the same deficiency
all right and then so i would have her
get rid of all the bad stuff no fried
foods no processed meats no oils no
gluten no wheat bread around notes no
sugar no carbonated drinks
and then i would have her take two
healthy brain and heart packs from out
to full roast everything twice a day i'd
get her one bottle a month at the msm so
you can take three of those twice either
big bottles so you should be able to do
that and it'll support and promote mains
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between the
vertebrae bone makes bone itself
and that will include
the connective tissue and arteries and
veins including hemorrhoids hemorrhoids
or just varicose veins in a funny place
okay
and then the charlie horses
um she could have it could be a
neurological thing where she's got low
back issues going on
and um
this results in a squeezing
of the sciatic nerves which cause stuff
going on downstream if you will uh
charlie horses you know in the back and
the legs and so on
um and then
that's where the msm is for don't forget
vitamin d three three of those twice a
day it wouldn't hurt also to throw in
the
um
beyond osteo fx liquid take an ounce of
that twice a day and be two quarts a
month
and then um don't forget the rebounders
first rank for the energy
and um
she could
take um
uh oh two
two or three doses a day of the
of the rebound
and um it has a hundred nutrients in it
as well as being an energy drink
okay
all right thank you so much dr wallach
and let's go to the next hand that is up
and forgive me is it olaf
go ahead and unmute you are on live with
dr wallach
wait you're
go ahead and unmute
do you see that
there you go yes it's good
hello
hello rebecca yes sir okay i apologize
uh what's your name again sir olaf i'm
from uh from the netherlands
olaf okay yes
thank you for taking your time for me
and all that you do
how can i help you
yeah i'm 46 years old i'm six foot one
and i weigh 195 pounds
my main concern is for about a year now
i've been having an increasing cram
feeling just on the right side of my
stomach right after meals and i get this
blown up feeling
right where my gallbladder seems to be
right on the ribcage
and the blown up feeling sometimes
extends a little bit to the center of my
stomach and it goes away after some
hours but there's
there seems to be this continuing
feeling of having a brick on the right
side
and i feel a bit lifeless and
um
[Music]
i used to have a little bit of red skin
around my waist but that's that's gone
now
um and
that's it and i was wondering if you
would have a
any advice on the supplements i could
order sure now do you have any ringing
ears or tinnitus or buzzing or any noise
any dizziness or vertigo
no sir
okay
um
do you have any
heart issues um anything like that
no i i don't have any heart issues
sometimes when i eat something wrong i
get a
heightened heartbeat but it's it's not a
it's not a heart issue
okay
by a heightened heartbeat you can't
thumping or
yes well it goes to 130 beats per minute
or so so okay so you get tacky cardi you
get a fast heart rate yes a fast heart
rate yes yes okay did you have to go to
an orthodontist when you were kids did
you have to have wear braces and
straighten out your teeth and all that
kind of stuff yes i did i did yes i did
okay
yeah you might have osteoporosis skull
squeezing the 10th cranial nerve which
can cause gastroparesis which causes all
the stomach stuff
and um
also this heart thing is tachycardia can
be caused by a squeezing of the 10th
cranial nerve by the skull it's called
tachycardia and become if it becomes
irregular
okay then that's called atrial
fibrillation and doctors want to
anesthetize you cut you open and put a
hot branding on on your heart and can
they kill a lot of patients with that
ablation treatment
but they think it's a heart issue but
it's really osteoporosis of the skull
all right okay yes
and um so especially you say oh you had
the dental problems you had braces when
you were a kid yes
yes yes so obviously you'd be born with
obviously approach to the skull so it's
not a thing of aging it has to do with
nutritional deficiencies okay so
um but you know you look like you're in
pretty good shape are you coloring your
hair or is that no it's the original
color it's still there
okay very good very good
all right
so at 195 pounds once you get rid of all
the bad foods as we said no fried foods
no processed meats no oils no gluten so
we brought around those no sugar no
carbohydrate eat like more of an asian
instead of a norwegian right or swede
okay
and then i want you to
get two healthy brain and heart patch
per month to full dose everything twice
a day two healthy brain and heart
pattern fold those twice a day get two
bottles a month of our msm so you can
take three at breakfast three at lunch
free dinner time and they will support
and promote maintenance repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue including the skin and arteries
and veins
and muscles
tendons and ligaments
bone matrix very important here that'll
also help the immune system all right
and so you might have what's called
gastroparesis where you're having this
sort of stomach cramp
after meals it's called gastroparesis
and when it gets bad enough doctors say
oh you got us you've got a gastric ulcer
you've got to take half your stomach out
or something they'd love to do those
surgeries right at any rate just
let's not go there no please
okay and so and then you can use our
rebounders for strength for the energy
piece
and
how's your sleep do you sleep well yes i
sleep very well yes okay good and i i
would go again with the rebound you
could take two or three doses of that a
day um just don't take it after four
o'clock because you might stay up all
night do you ever get sleepy or drowsy
watching tv after a meal at night time
no time no no i don't oh no okay good
all right well let's go with this um i
think you're gonna have a great great
testimony so call us every couple of
weeks
and let us know how things are going
because if you do these things i believe
you know within a couple weeks you're
going to see a huge benefit within a
couple more weeks
almost this stuff can be all gone
certainly within 90 days it'll be gone
we see so many patients with this sort
of picture you have
and it's the beginning of things
happening
and so if you catch it at this stage
it's very easy to turn around very
quickly okay
i used to order the ultimate enzymes for
my stomach but you're advising me to
take the msm ultra
well what i what i want you to do is
take the msm also yes because that's a
totally different thing the msm is for
the osteoporosis of the skull
squeezing that 10th cranial nerve the
vagus nerve which
controls the rate and rhythm of the
heartbeat okay it controls the lungs uh
do you ever get hiccups or anything like
that
um no rarely really oh okay yeah but it
also causes gastroparesis as pain in the
stomach when he gets bad enough and
people really really are complaining the
doctors well we got to take out half
your stomach because you got an ulcer
they don't even do an x-ray or anything
but they hear that pain thing they say
oh you got an ulcer no gastroparesis
osteoporosis is called squeezing that
10th training nerve okay ah okay i
understand
yes very good very much doc we look
forward to hearing from you again olaf
yes i'll keep you updated thank you very
much please
thank you yes thank you
all right thank you olaf now dr wallach
the next
question
is from monica she says i'm vegetarian i
love lentils any health problems eating
them every day
i accidentally muted dr wallach go ahead
and unmute dr wallach
there you go can you hear me now yes
okay
i love vegetarians i eat them every day
roasted and baked not fried okay but now
all kidding aside here
um
if you're a vegetarian you really really
must supplement and this is the story of
the book
epigenetics it goes through all these
diets there's you know like 50 different
diets from all these
want to be
knowledgeable people about health and
everything and wonder health fit people
vegetarian diets vegan diets
um so forth
they got diets named after cities
it is crazy all right the north shore
diet the south shore diet
the
san francisco diet
all these diets
because they think this is why people
live longer we have to appreciate
that
your possibility for life a human
life expectancy is 155. in america our
average is 75.
when you look at longevity worldwide we
rank 48th
when you look at
longevity compared to just
industrialized nations we rank 17th
okay but when you look at the world we
rank 48th there's 47 other countries
whose peoples live on us
okay
and
when you look at uh italy they live to
be 83. you look at australia they live
to be 83. you look at um
let's see vietnam they live to be 76.
the uk lives 81. new zealand lives
82. uh the hunzas lived to be 120 what
oh the hundreds lived 120 that's their
average but their oldest ones lived to
be 160
okay and then of course japan lives me
and so and oh oh here's one medical
doctors in america now listen up here
this is important medical doctors in
america this is cdc just six months ago
medical doctors in america especially if
they work in the emergency room their
average lifespan is 57.
57 is the average lifespan of medical
doctors who work in emergency rooms
now
doctors if you get run over by a truck
and you're bleeding internally i would
go to emergency room but
if you want to have a long healthy life
you want to get a hold of the book
epigenetics the book
hell's kitchen
uh you want to get a hair now it says
get a hold of that book rare earth's
been cures get on the 90 essential
nutrients praise the lord and pass the
90 don't forget about that cd and the
dvd praise the lord and pass the 90.
we take people who've been in comas for
eight years being fed through a g-tube
in a nursing home
we put our stuff our nutritional program
through that g-tube
three times a day
and
within
three days
they wake up and go back to work they
didn't realize they were in a coma for
eight years
hello
okay
a body needs these 90 essential
nutrients so being a vegetarian
lentils is not the answer to
longevity or not the nice thing about
lentils is
they're kind of like flat beans
okay
they don't have any gluten in them
and so
lentils are very very useful from the
standpoint you're going to get it's
almost like having vegetables out of
your garden
and um but you want to make sure
that uh you're also not eating any
gluten no wheat powder in oats no wheat
butter and oats i don't care if they're
organic organic just means no chemicals
organic doesn't mean safer it just means
no chemicals
if you eat wheat it's organic it's still
got gluten in it
organic wheat will still kill you
okay so i hope that kind of gets through
eat eat like an asian rice i like wild
rice because you can get brown rice red
rice yellow rice white rice
because you're going to get your
nutrition
from the healthy brain and heart pack
that way you're guaranteeing are you
going to put dirt from texas or saudi
arabia into your car it's only 10 cents
a quart for a quarter dirt from saudi
arabia
why would you spend a buck a quart for
oil when you can spend 10 cents for a
quarter dirt there's bound to be some
oil in that dirt because it's from saudi
arabia or from texas or oklahoma
an idiot crazy drunk wouldn't do that to
their car
when a doctor says oh just eat well you
get everything you need don't waste your
money and buy it
my doctor says i can get everything i
need just by eating well
well how old is your doctor well he died
a couple years ago well how was he well
he was only 47. well i wouldn't take
much
truck with what he said
okay back to you rebecca
so dr wellick it makes you wonder okay
we're ranked 48. yet people come here
for medical treatment
well that's because our medical doctors
are great salesmen they put out around
the world
that we have the best medical system in
and they get paid the most i mean we
spend more money we spend more money we
spend two-thirds of the world's
expenditure for healthcare
here right in the united states we spend
two-thirds of the world's expenditure
for healthcare in the united states
but we only rank 48th
in longevity
okay
yeah so
i personally i i declined three
different back surgeries
and i'm still thankful that i did dr
wallach because today i don't need them
and it was all suspicious well see
you're not only beautiful you're smart
i do try i do try
um so dr wallace the next comment in the
chat is
oh a relative of mine over 65 years old
has recently started
hot flashes this is a gentleman who is
five foot seven
165 pounds what would you recommend for
a man
that has just started to have hot
flashes in his mid to late 60s
okay
well here's a guy he needs to
um
check out his blood sugar do a
do a um uh
his own blood sugar test
okay do a six hour
where you you know
you're you're doing a
blood sugar
uh every hour for six hours after you
eat and then it could be for just from
reactive hypoglycemia getting hot
flashes
okay if it's uh if he has ed along with
it erectile dysfunction
okay
that's another story
but it wouldn't hurt for him to really
know what's going on
so i'd get to have him get the book rare
has been cured go to chapter 10 11 get a
hair analysis with the information there
it'll tell them how to get the hair
analysis don't forget to put the check
in because they won't run the test
without the check
and um he'll see what's going on with
his absorption with minerals what's
going on if he has toxic minerals and so
forth
but then and you say 165 167 pounds
somewhere in there 130 um yeah so 165
pounds okay 165 pounds so yeah i wanted
to have
um get rid of all the bad foods and then
uh two healthy brain heart packs per
month two health brain heart factors
about the full roast everything twice a
day
he also needs the msm
i'd take three of those twice a day
that's one bottle a month uh and him
take the
uh sweeties go ahead and take three of
those twice a day
and
uh it wouldn't hurt also for him to have
the um zera test
you take i take three of those i'm 83
years old and take three zero tests
twice a day that's two bottles a month
and it gives us hertoli cells and his
testicles the nutrients
that they need to make testosterone he's
got to eat three eggs twice a day with
soft yolks soft boiled
soft poached soft soft scrambling butter
hard boiled eggs and fried eggs won't
count
all right and so let's start there but i
do want him to get that hair analysis to
see if he's got any toxic metals
see if he's absorbing
because if all the if all the minerals
are low
then
he's not absorbing
if there's sort of all over the place
that means he's absorbing okay
so we need to know all that information
but uh to taking these programs we'll
get him on the right start path because
hot flashes will be caused by blood
sugar issue uh don't forget the sweeties
three of those twice a day
um
and it could be due to lack of hormones
if he's not eating eggs he's taking
statin drugs he's unstable drugs he's
got to wean over that don't just cold
turkey off the stand drugs but once he
starts with the zero test
um
as he begins to feel better he can
slowly reduce the amounts of the
statin drugs he's taking
because 75 of your brain weight is
cholesterol repeat that 75 percent of
your brain weight is cholesterol
and 95 of the weight of testosterone and
estrogen is cholesterol
so you don't want to live a life without
cholesterol
if you have any if you have you know
like a month's supply
of um
of statin drugs i would box it up and
give it as a christmas present to your
doctor
even if it's if even if your doctor is a
female have her give it to her husband
all right dr wallach thank you so much
for that
um our next question actually is the
next hand that is up so
nick
go ahead and unmute yourself and if
you're able to turn your camera on that
would be fantastic as well
and nick puts in here and we need to
give a great big thank you to grandma
who is 80 plus years old who has sent
nick to watch our program
okay grandma's pretty smart
hi
um so i just have the fibroid issues and
uh i have to be
if i don't stay laying down for four
days straight during my cycle
then i end up in the emergency room with
um
what feels like massive bursting going
on inside my uterus
okay fibroids
okay let's see what color is your hair
uh it's brown and i don't really have
much grays but i i bleach it
okay but i could tell you coloring your
hair so you do have some gray hair and
how old are you
um i'm i'm 37 but i i like i only have
like maybe five or six gray hairs it
doesn't matter if you have one you have
gray hair right but i mean they're
they're you really can't see them
it doesn't matter they're a symptom
they're a symptom of a nutritional
deficiency that's what i'm getting at do
you have any do you have any varicose
veins or spider veins your feet or
ankles nope do you have do you have
hemorrhoids
nope
nope do you have any fast heart rate
nope any skin problems eczema dermatitis
psoriasis no any bowel problems
constipation diarrhea
none
none any respiratory problems hiccups
asthma bronchitis
nothing no diabetes no hybrid pressure
no other issues other than one gray hair
i didn't say one i said like seven
okay
so
um basically what i would do
um and i apologize how much do you weigh
135 okay
what kind of work do you do
i work on a farm
okay good girl
farm girl
you raise crops or animals animals
goats pigs sheep cows
goats chickens pigeons ducks geese
okay
all right
um
what i want you to do is get rid of all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat by round oats no sugar
no carbon or drinks here the diet one's
got to go
and 135 pounds once you take one healthy
brain and hard pack per month
and i want you to get another bottle of
arsenium not selenium from walgreens but
arsenic but it has five cofactors in
there the cofactors in our selenium
there's one bottle in the healthy banana
heart pack so i want you to take six a
day two of breakfast lunch with dinner
or three twice a day
because they're going
that the white here you have one or two
or three you have they'll go away that's
telling you you're absorbing properly
but also is to prevent you from having a
life threatening
event
because the same
things that are caused by the
nutritional deficiencies like white here
also cause varicose veins and
hemorrhoids and aneurysms of the brain
and aneurysms of the ar and the heart
coronary arteries and so forth which are
life-threatening so you want to watch
that but they also help with fibrous
tissue including the connective tissue
in the uterus people forget
that the uterus
has connective tissue
okay because the uterus is a muscle has
connective tissue just like your arm
muscle your leg muscle and so forth and
so fibroids
okay
are fibrous connective tissue
inflammation in the walls of the uterus
all right
so
um
you want to have one healthy brain and
heart pack another bottle of flames and
take three of our same twice a day a
half of those are anything else twice a
day i want you to
get our
zera femme xerifem go ahead and take
three of those twice a day there's two
bowels a month of our zera femme
that'll give your ovaries what they need
to make estrogen and progesterone
properly don't forget three eggs twice a
day uh you're raising chickens i hope
you're getting some eggs but you need to
have the eggs soft boiled soft poached
soft soft scrambled butter no fried eggs
no no hard-boiled eggs
and
then call us every couple of weeks
because you're going to have a great
testimony
all right you're suffering from a common
scenario of things that young women
suffer from
because they're giving up eggs because
they don't want cholesterol
and then they can't make they can't make
estrogen
[Laughter]
and i eat pretty healthy i don't drink
soda i don't drink fried foods i don't
eat gluten i haven't done that for years
i've been pretty good for a while okay
good you know if you had to know why
this was happening yeah because you have
deficiencies yes you have deficiencies
eating healthy
is a what should i say
is a self
it'll make you feel good by saying i eat
healthy but it doesn't matter uh no do
you give
um just you just throw wheat out to the
chickens or you give them chicken
pellets
no they actually get grain they get
actual corn grain and then they get a
bird seed they don't they don't get they
don't get wheat we don't give them wheat
okay do they get any like alfalfa
pellets with vitamins and minerals in
them they get a regular pellet that does
not have wheat in it but it does have
vitamins and minerals in it correct
okay so you're giving a supplement
program to your chickens and to your
goats and all your other animals
but you have to do the same thing i do
the same thing
so you're taking the chickens
alfalfa pellets
no i take my own supplements for humans
really i take chickens
okay but um i'm trying to make a point
here
because you know because i i'm not
unders you're just telling me to take
some pills but you're not really telling
me like this is the exact same this is
why i don't go to doctors because
okay stop okay i want you to listen
okay the reason why you have this
problem you have a nutritional deficit
you have multiple nutritional
deficiencies you have fibromyalgia of
the walls of your uterus
you have fibromyalgia the walls of your
uterus you have fibromyalgia the walls
of your uterus okay
and so you need to stay away from the
bad stuff so you can absorb the
nutrition then you need to take the
nutrients including the msm the healthy
brain and heart pack the vitamin d3
and also the xerifm to get all the
nutrients into your body so it can
rebuild all the connective tissue in the
walls of your uterus
people get the same thing happening in
the walls of their arteries and veins
they get the same thing happening in
their tendons and ligaments and their
discs between their vertebrae their skin
and so forth
okay
but you have a great story you'll you'll
be able to give us a great testimony
when you do these things
but
in the book epigenetics i go into the
fact that all these animals we raise on
farms we give them all these pellets all
the vitamins and minerals in it and the
first thing that somebody will tell me
is i eat well
i just want to pull my hair out
you're not giving yourself alfalfa
pellets with all these vitamins and
minerals in it no i eat well
okay that's why you have a problem
because you can't get enough nutrition
just by eating well
because the plant
okay are you still there
nikki
no she has left
oh yeah
yeah she didn't want she
she didn't want to hear me
no and and dr wallach you know coming
from a point where i used to supplement
a lot
but there were missing pieces that were
still causing decline in health
yeah but she's got to be open
to saying okay
you've been doing this for so long
let's try something different yeah we'll
say taking centrum centrum has 27
nutrients in it
from rock
well you're still missing the other part
of the 90.
that too
there you go
yeah so
yeah i supplement but just
being better off eating the chicken
pellets than you are eating centrum
yeah
most definitely most definitely
so and just just
you know something to think about for
everybody
if you've been on a program for a long
time and you are still
experiencing things that cause cr
especially those things that cause
great discomfort
in your body
that's your body saying hey i'm still
missing something
so
just give this program
90 days
what dr wallach is recommending
and
i know
you will be feeling a difference i know
i did
i mean i remember those severe cramps
it's been
over five years since i've had them and
i'm just so thankful for that those hot
flashes
thing of the past so thankful for that
it's in it all the only thing i did
different was start following dr
wallach's good foods bad foods list
which you can find at askdoclive.com
and then getting on a
quality supplementation program that is
put together
intentionally putting the 90 essential
nutrients in every dose
i mean dr while like you you're just
your mind is incredible
and i and i thank god and i know so many
who thank god for you and what you have
done i want to head to that list of
thanking god he's my hero
i know you are because your story is
absolutely incredible
i mean
i have so many people with with children
and it seems like more and more
children that are not able to function
in everyday life not able to be in a
standard classroom yet i have clients
whose children now
are taking full loads
in college
and doing well
that have have been on the spectrum
with
with very severe autism
and it's just
the parents are so thankful
the
kids i'm sure are thankful too
but i know as a parent to see your child
struggle and then to see them excel
is one of the greatest things in the
world that's right praise the lord and
pass to 90.
that's right
let's go to the next hand that is up and
that is renee
renee
go ahead and unmute yourself and if
you're able to turn your camera on that
would be fantastic as well
hi
there we go hello hi hi everyone
i'm calling with a follow-up
okay
uh let's see i called in september
and i've been taking all of the
uh suggestions
and i'm feeling a lot better
what were you what were your major
complaints in september i've built into
tens of thousands of people since then
i know it's a gallbladder so
wanting to remove my gallbladder
and gastritis those were the two
main
yes so i'm taking the the healthy pack
the msn ultra
the
fucoid z
uh let's see what else
um the ultimate selenium
the um let's see even the cal toddy
yeah let's see what else i have
everything here
i just have to say i i remember when you
came on the first time renee and i could
see the pain in your face and you are
just glowing
yeah you have such a beautiful smile
yeah
ah thank you yes yeah i feel a lot
better i have
um
my mental clarity it's a little bit
better
uh
yeah i feel i feel good the pain in my
gallbladder i get it sometimes it's but
it's
it's uh not that sharp pain where i have
to go to the emergency room it's
um it feels like it's fading away
yeah so you still have a little bit of
awareness but it's fading away
[Music]
yes
well thank you it's a great testimony
yes thank you i need a refill on
everything so i'll be doing that soon i
also have my husband
uh taking the supplements as well
and uh everyone in the household we're
all losing weight
my son with autism
because we're changing our diet i notice
um just this week
there's less behaviors
isn't that amazing
mm-hmm
yeah i'm excited about that part
yeah you won't have to lock him up in an
institution
oh my god
that's the nightmare yeah
yeah thank you okay well thank you so
much for the testimony god bless
god bless you too renee
you're welcome
and i i do want to mention that you know
the people that come on and give their
testimonies i don't know that they're
coming on to give their testimonies
um but we definitely appreciate
people coming on and just
sharing their gratitude dr wallach
and the body is the body is gonna thank
you for it
you're gonna think you know whoever is
responsible for referring you
to the program to the nutrition
and it all comes back to a maine who a
man who
was given
just
i don't i don't know how to say it dr
wallach well here's here's the way i
think of it i rebecca god has definitely
given us to given you to us for a reason
and i am grateful for that well
here's what i think about it i've
thought about and thought about and
thought about why why was i picked and i
thought i was picked because i was a
veterinarian first
and uh so many things i've done
um
this would be something that i'd be in
the same
office with noah
okay it's it's like noah in the ark uh
you know and the other day i talked
about the um
uh rhino express
book and all the rhino stuff that i did
and everything
uh and that's just one little piece of
it because i do that not only with rhino
but i do that with people
of all races in all countries and so
forth
and so i look at that and i thought you
know this is kind of like a nose and the
ark thing that i'm doing
and that's how i look at it as kind of
like
a um
apprentice of noah i'll i'll consider
myself an apprentice of noah
there you go
and um christy just put in the comments
i was on what i thought was a good
vitamin program since 2003
but i sure wasn't getting the minerals
and vitamins i needed so she felt
as well
now i have gene dr wallach who put in
the comments what would help with tia's
transit ismatic attack
my friend is 78 years old 5 foot 6
inches
female 160 pounds
gray hair
the doctor has prescribed blood thinners
aspirin stating
for blood pressure
the last tia was only two weeks ago
after the previous two weeks after the
previous one
okay is this person
that jeans talking about are they
already on the program
um it does not say so i'm going to say
that this this is probably a new person
okay when you have asthma okay that's a
nutritional deficiency
uh when you have gray hair that's a
and so
um
they need to 160 pounds get off all the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
meats no oils no glutens no wheat nobody
around those no sugar no carbonated
drinks even the diet one's got to go
and then ideally they would take two
healthy brain and heart packs for a
month full dose everything at breakfast
full-blown dinner time i'd also take the
msm go ahead and take three of those
twice a day that's one bottle a month
and there's reason i throw the msm in is
because
sometimes um the asthma
can be caused by just a simple there's a
particular deficiency it will cause
asthma by itself but also
you can get copd
which is
oftentimes misinterpreted as asthma
which is caused by the squeezing of the
10th cranial nerve regardless of age by
this osteoporosis of the skull
and so here
um two healthy brain heart patterns per
month one bottle of the msm so you take
three of those twice a day
also
the
uh let's see here i would also throw in
the fucoid z take three of those twice a
day as two vowels a month
and then
uh it wouldn't hurt also
to take
some extra of the
collagen peptides collagen peptides go
in the morning drink put in a scoop or
two and the evening drink put in a scoop
or two of the collagen peptides and
that's going to help with cartilage and
ligaments and tendons people forget
that your lungs your trachea is all
cartilage and and ligaments
your bronchials all
carbon
and and so forth and
ligaments and tendons
and holding up this little grape like
clusters of your cells
in your lungs
but if you take the weight of everything
minus the water
your trachea and your bronchi and all
the other little
things holding up all these little
clusters of cells
are
connective tissue and so that's why it's
so important to have the msm when you
have lung issues
and so uh i don't know
who diagnosed this person with asthma is
it copd is it asthma yeah t-i-a is what
was mentioned
okay
um
transient ischemic attacks yeah
yeah okay where they they can you know
kind of
have stuff going on in their brain stuff
going on in their heart and so forth
and usually
they don't know this but the people with
these problems will have liver problems
they'll have maybe reactive hypoglycemia
they'll eat a meal these are the people
who fall asleep
half hour after they eat watching tv
at dinner time these are the ones that
get into car wrecks they've had so many
car wrecks this year it's beat the
records it's our record of ever the
worst number of car wrecks fatal car
wrecks in america
and i think it's because
people
are falling asleep while they're driving
and they're crossing the center line
doing head-on crashes and so forth
because they have reactive hypoglycemia
and if everybody were to be taking the
healthy random heart pack and extra
sweeties wouldn't hurt for this person
to take some
three sweeties twice maybe two battles a
month also for that
potential issue
and um
all these problems are going to go away
i agree now dr wellick i just opened up
an email
and
[Music]
it let me get back to it
so um thomas is 75 years by four there
will be 75 years old before the end of
this year
he just worked out an hour and a half
closed out his gym and sat down at the
kitchen table and his bp was 115 over 63
and a pulse of 82. i've been taking
several of the youngevity pr products
over the decades he and his wife and
they
discussed health issues but they're
doing fabulous
sounds like yeah
yeah i mean 75 years old with a bp of
115 over 63 and a pulse of 82 after an
hour and 20 minute workout that is
fabulous
it sounds like me
yes
so okay dr wallace i have a confession
okay
are you being naughty
well no i was not but my my body got to
experience firsthand this whole thing
that's going on
with the pandemic and
i am so thankful that it was nothing
more than a headache in a slight favor
of 99.9
now were you positive did you get a
positive covid
so another member of the family
that lives here in the house with me did
test positive with the same symptoms
so and we got some tiredness
and loss of smell loss of taste
but
you know everything went through i did a
it worked out to be 4 500 mile
round trip did you die
no
i didn't i didn't even feel like death
warmed over
i'm like super thankful for that and
there's no way i would have driven that
long without the good nutrition
and
keeping me awake and not having to feel
like i have to go to that
travel food
you know it's like i had no cravings i
could drive
and and got the trip done with no
problem and
i'm very proud of you
and i and i took so i took the fucoid z
i took the vitamin d
of course this is all in addition to the
healthy body pack
i take took extra selenium
and i even took some oxy body because i
know that a lot of people have
respiratory issues when they get
attacked with this and
um thankfully
no one in our family because i had them
all on this as well and we did the
colloidal silver we did the ultimate
zinc you know we wanted to make sure
that we
attack everything
and
[Music]
and we were we were able to come through
i mean even my mom at 85 years old my
dad is 83
you know we all we all came through with
no problems
so well very proud of you and thank you
for sharing your testimony well and and
i just i you know
so many times people will get this oh so
somebody so and so tested positive and
they just get this doom and gloom
and i'm hoping that this can be just a
light of hope for people that
it does not have to be doom and gloom
yeah if you do everything right if you
do everything no vaccines are you know
perfect but so if you get you know if
you get a breakthrough infection you
take all your 90 essential nutrients
stay away from the bad stuff
the odds are you will survive and
flourish
yes
and i'm all about putting only natural
things in my body now so
um
i i'm just i'm thankful
that i've got those raw ingredients on
board that can keep us going
now i think we might have one more hand
okay we have time for one more yeah
or it's a question she didn't get her
hand actually up but anne is wondering
how long on your program before relief
from osteoporosis of the skull
she's experiencing right eye closure
so ann if you're able to
to um
come on with us
that would be fabulous so dr wally can
ask you some questions to make sure that
he's giving the right
okay well we we've done this literally
millions of times so we're very very
very up on the answer that question
it's not unusual for people to see
results within two weeks
of noticeable results
even people that can't close their hands
and we get them on this program you know
they're able to play the piano in two
weeks it's amazing and then
um same way with
dizziness
ringing in the ears tinnitus
vertigo
loss to the sense of smell
gradually losing vision
all of these things go away
or improve significantly within weeks
and then
sometimes it might take a month or two
to completely go away but you'll see
recognizable clinical improvement within
a couple of weeks i always say give doc
and i think you know that term give doc
90 days
and
give doc 90 days because we rarely fail
to see benefit
um
within 90 days okay uh almost always
like 98 of the time we'll see benefit
within a couple of weeks we'll see
significant benefit within four weeks
within six eight weeks sometimes
everything all the bad stuff is gone
and certainly within 90 days
it's just
it happened so many literally millions
of times over the last 50 years that we
just
have unimpeachable evidence and that's
why i want people to get the books
uh epigenetics the book um
hell's kitchen
and then of course we have the the basic
four books let's play doctor let's say
herbal doctor passport roman therapy is
all in your head and those four books
will go through over 600 different
diseases and teach you what to do for
them
and you'll pay the wholesale prices at
youngevity if you become a preferred
customer you become an associate
and we're talking about being a you know
somebody who's a business builder here
and a trainer
um
you will
actually
get paid on a monthly basis based on the
volume you create but whether you're a
customer or an associate
if you get on auto ship i will pay the
shipping so you're going to save a lot
of money on the shipping i have people
who've been with me for 50 years they've
they've shown me
they've saved
between 10 and 20 000
in shipping costs over the 50 years
um
because they became
they got on auto ship and they they
never had to pay shipping and so
it's one of those things where people
say well supplements are so expensive no
why would you pay retail and go you know
go to the drugstore in the grocery store
and the health food store when you can
get them from us at wholesale
why would you just buy them on occasion
and have to pay the shipping when you
get on auto ship and we will pay the
shipping
and so and then you start helping other
people every time they buy something you
get a little piece of that action
and so it doesn't take long you get rid
of the bad foods you're saving enough
money
by getting rid of the bad foods which
are very expensive
to
pay for your products and this is not
difficult if you can read the fifth
grade reading level you can do this you
don't need to be a doctor you don't need
to be a nurse
anything like that
this is something that everybody can do
we deal with all races all religions all
um countries
and
we have
the dead doctors don't lie
we have that one in nine languages and i
have my two newest cds one is dr
wallach's laws of
of um
let's see here dr wallach's laws of
photosynthetic disruption and global
warming
it shows that global warming has nothing
to do
with what's going on uh it's not fossil
fuels or anything like that it's another
story so you got to get that cd to
listen to and you go oh my gosh
and then we have the newest one
is the manchurian prescription which i
speak for two three four minutes in
english it's translated by professional
translators into mandarin chinese i
speak for two or three or four minutes
in mandarin chinese this goes on for
about an hour and a half manchurian
prescription is a zoom that i did into
eight
um asian countries
and so again we have the cd dead doctors
don't lie in nine languages including
korean and mandarin cantonese
um
and so forth
so this is not difficult we have tools
that will help you deal with chinatown
why not why not have why not sponsor
some people who own restaurants and and
acupuncture clinics in chinatown why not
work with them also we have stuff in
their language that they can understand
very clearly and so let's go for it
okay over to you
yes let's go for it and i can't believe
we were at the top of the hour once
again
with the ass asstock live and dr wallach
on behalf of myself and ruth ellen
sanchez and jonty mccollier thank you
again for another two great hours of
information
sharing how we can be empowered and take
control of our health dr wallach
well thank you for the opportunity
god bless you god bless your team
and look forward to next week
and thank you everybody who has gotten
on with us today all of you that are
watching the replays
you can be empowered of your health get
back with the person that shared this
program with you and ask them how you
too can start filling the difference
again go to
askdoclive.com we've got dr wallach's
most popular publications there you've
got the good foods bad foods list and
the replay of all of our programs at
askdoclive.com
and feel free if you've never spoken to
anybody use that contact us option and
one of our certified holistic health
coaches we'll get back with you have a
great day everybody bye for now thanks
thank you so much rebecca god bless john
t ruth ellen bye bye
bye everyone
bye-bye